arena roja cuatro habitaciones un
gimnasio y una granja vertical dentro de
una casa de 160 metros cuadrados impresa
en 3D Este es el proyecto de la Nasa que
busca estimular la superficie de marte
en la tierra
Entonces el análogo de exploración de
rendimiento y salud de la tripulación O
chapía se desarrolló como una simulación
de superficie de Marte de un año con la
intención de que podamos tener una
tripulación aislada y confinada con
restricciones realistas de Marte
una esclusa conduce a una reconstrucción
al aire libre del que sería el entorno
Marciano Aunque todavía se encuentra
dentro del hangar en el lugar también
hay una estación meteorológica una
máquina para fabricar ladrillos y un
pequeño invernadero además hay una cinta
rodante en la que los voluntarios
caminarán suspendidos de correas para
simular la gravedad del vecino planeta
la NASA planea monitorear su salud
física y mental para comprender mejor la
fortaleza de los humanos en un ambiente
adverso
Además del aislamiento el confinamiento
y la gran distancia estarían cosas como
poder llevarnos bien entonces cuando
estás en un hábitat pequeño con ya sabes
otras tres personas Eso puede
desgastarte con el tiempo
Los investigadores pondrán a prueba
periódicamente la respuesta de la
tripulación a situaciones de estrés como
la restricción de la disponibilidad de
agua o los fallos de los equipos cuatro
voluntarios en el verano boreal
comenzarán la primera prueba de cómo
sería la vida de las futuras misiones al
planeta rojo que están planeadas para
algún momento de la década de 2030
mientras la NASA continúa con su
programa artemis con el que busca enviar
una misión tripulada para la exploración
de la luna